- Hello I'm Paul F. Thompkins.
This is a bow tie.
This is a lie.
I'm gonna show you
how to tie a bow tie.
And then you're gonna know.
Here's what you do,
you have your bow tie.
Put it around your
stupid neck okay
put it under your shirt collar
button up your collar, be nice
then pull the right side down
you want it so that
the left side will be
half the length
of the right side
you will cross the
right, the long end
over the left, the
short end, like so.
Then you will flip the long
end over like this right
tighten it, let it drop
down, this is easy so far.
You're barely doing
anything, I'm mad at you.
Then this back part, you're
gonna take it like this
flip her over like that, this
is where you're making the bow
do you see the magic,
it is revealed,
everything is illuminated
hold the bow like this, hold
the back part like this.
Let the front part
flop over then you are
going to bring
these ends together.
The fabric here of the back part
you're going to
push this through
the little hole that you
have created behind the bow.
Did you see the little
hole see there's a thing
in there right that's
where the bow goes through.
Push the fabric through
the little hole.
I'm trying to give you
a good angle on this
because a lot of tutorial
videos will not show you that
and it'll be very frustrating
and then you'll end up
with a repetitive stress
injury in your arm
like someone who is me
pull the alternating sides,
the back, front, free ends
and the closed loops,
pull them back and forth
to make small adjustments to
the tightness of the knot.
Its okay if it looks
a little sloppy
that's how people know
that you actually did it
like a real big boy or girl.
That's your bow tie, I
did this without a mirror
and you can too once you
got it you got it for life.
It's just like
smoking cigarettes
which I'm assuming you're doing.
Or should be just kidding
that's for dumb people
I hope you learned
something and that something
that I hope you learned
is how to tie a bow tie
because that's what I was
trying to f**king get you to do.
I'm Paul F. Tompkins
and this has been
an at midnight master class.